Joey Ramone and Marky Ramone coming in
to retire right now sad day
coming to retire on our show Robin Joey
is out there screaming that I ripped off
his look all right marquise de Joie he's
not he's taking a leak
he's taking a leak come in he went to
the bathroom what what is he doing is he
nervous no I don't think so
how you been man okay are you really
breaking up or is it just I don't want
to break up but John and Joey do they do
and Joey's for real I feel it's the
wrong time sergeant talk to me seriously
about this don't don't don't downplay
this you guys have said Howard it's you
in the flesh it's me man oh let's get it
to the retirement have a new seat talk
as a retiree all right go ahead the
public have been supporting you no no
Sonny we're just like radio hasn't and
he that has other things what are you
supposed to do you know I mean you you
know you started something a thing
called punk rock everybody milk and made
a fortune and now we feel that uh you
know there's nowhere else to go
we're just you sound a little pistol
happy we're happy for punk heavy metal
that was in the eighties you're upset
I'm gonna tell you why upset cuz you
guys you guys have been a little
diplomatic here Melissa shocked yes you
do you guys started something you pushed
it everyone was very supportive in the
beginning and now you feel your own son
well Howard you're an originator that's
right and you've maintained that's right
and you fought the government and you
fought the FCC so nobody's gonna support
me I mean they're all fighting people
won't even like I mean we didn't get
that even that kind of appreciation well
you know you guys
you guys are like the Phil Donahue a
punk you started right and then like all
of a sudden everyone else is doing it
English like give us credit now for like
you know yeah we appreciate it don't you
right and I feels the wrong time to
break up a day they want to retire and
what are you gonna do now that you
retired what are you gonna do I have my
own project coming out I don't want to
push that now get a new band together
Joe is that what you're trying to do
minimal radio program you're gonna get a
radio program you guys can't retire you
too much fun yeah we we love each other
though alright listen I am sad to see
The Ramones retire for one I'm a
supporter you really somebody moving
away other guitarists John's going to
Bella T Beverly Hills he's got a free
port he's gonna retire and he's not
gonna play anymore
right and play golf right and that's
what are you gonna do Joey
I'm gonna play badminton what do you do
just hang out yo you got enough money to
be retired set for your life okay you're
comfortable comfortable you know I got a
good couch right play ping pong I'm
someone sad to see it but I understand
that your frustrations were the industry
all right I mean it's kind of like it's
it's you know it's kind of a personal
satisfaction